The SNORT system has
four logical components.
The packet decoder possesses each
capture packet to identify the protocol
headers at it's data link network
transport and application layers.
The detection engine does the actual
work of intrusion detection.
The detection engine checks each
packet against a set of rules.
That is,
each packet is checked against all rules
to determine if the packet matches
the characters defined by a rule.
A rule that matches the decoded
packet would trigger the action
specified by the rule.
If no rule matches the packet,
the detection engine
will discard the packet.
For each packet that matches a rule,
the rule specifies what login or
alerting options are to be taken.
When the login selection is selected,
the logger stores the detected
packet in human readable format.
This can then use the log files for
later analysis.
For each detected packet,
an alert can be sent.
An alert can be sent to a file,
a database, or an email, etc.